good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is scp-198 class safe
special containment procedures scp-198
Aroon at site 17 to date SCP 191 has not
made any requests for furnishings or
entertainment current furnishings
include one wooden frame futon with a 15
centimeter pad and standard cotton bed
sheets and blankets all sheets are to be
sterilized each morning according to
standard procedures the futon pad itself
will be replaced every six months and
the old pad discarded through
incineration one standard 220 volt type
G power outlet with an emergency cutoff
box fuse circuit breaker and manual non
insulating guillotine located outside
the cell one standard hazardous waste
disposal unit liquid and solid waste all
drainage tubes shall lead directly into
an incinerator unit scp-198 to be
dressed in loose sleeveless garments
made of 100% long staple cotton fresh
clothing will be provided once daily
with used garments sterilized according
to standard procedures bathing is to be
done once every evening in a wash tub
filled with a solution of water and
baking soda feeding in the form of a
sterile saline solution supplemented
with vitamins minerals antibiotics and a
mild anesthetic shall be carried out
twice a day via injection into a
metallic tube located in the base of the
neck SCP 191 is capable of limited self
care including draining waste and
recharging internal batteries a log
shall be captive power consumption and
any unusual changes in power usage
reported to supervising staff
daily inspections for injuries should be
carried out after bathing jet scp-198
documents 191 alpha special medical
needs and 191 alpha supplemental repair
of non biological components before
administering care at least two armed
guards are to be present in the room and
anytime that personnel have had contact
with scp-198 rands loosen screen may be
utilized for privacy purposes standard
anti computer countermeasures are
ineffective as SCP 191 s components have
been hardened against electromagnetic
pulse EMP description SCP 191 is a
female human child approximately years
old it is believed to have been a test
subject of several experimental
surgeries performed by the late doctor
see below one eighty percent of the left
half of the face and skull have been
removed with the eye and ear replaced by
a complex transceiver system that allows
it to receive and transmit not only
visual and auditory input but a wider
spectrum of electromagnetic radiation
ranging from low-frequency radio to
high-energy gamma rays the lower jaw
teeth and larynx have been removed and
replaced with the esophagus has been
rerouted to an artificial orifice at the
back of the neck
feeding tube and the trachea rerouted
directly to an air filtration device due
to these alterations scp-198 below of
speech although it has been reported
occasionally vocalizing distress through
rapid respiration number two an
input/output device has been placed into
the right forearm replacing the radius
and ulna bones the device contains
interfaces for a variety of modern and
obsolete formats including USB Ethernet
firewire and din eight pin as well as
seven other interfaces corresponding to
no known formats the device can be
accessed by pulling back the skin over
the right arm like a shirt sleeve number
three a 24 core processor array has been
implanted in the brain which translates
input from all artificial components
essentially allowing a CP 191 to read
and write computer data without the use
of an external interface internal
communication is carried out through
fiber optic cables implanted through the
glial cells and the entire nervous
system damage to the brain stem and
cerebellum due to the implantation
procedure has severely damaged SCP 191 s
motor skills number for the right hand
and right fore leg have been replaced
with artificial components consisting
primarily of steel carbon fiber and an
unknown polymer like substance the
exposed areas of tissue are susceptible
to injury and infection due to damage to
the spinothalamic tract SCP 191 has
reduced pain and temperature sensitivity
in its limbs
reconstructive surgery by dr. pol was
able to provide some relief but regular
doses of antibiotics and anal G's --ax
are still required number five
number six the lungs heart and major
blood vessels have been replaced with
mechanical analogs it has been
determined that this system would allow
scp-198 'add after death and may have
actually number seven the digestive
system has been completely reconfigured
to the point where regular food intake
is both unnecessary and dangerous waste
is now disposed of via a drainage system
located in the lower back and consists
of a thick dark gray viscous slime
consisting primarily number eight the
reproductive organs uterus ovaries etc
have been removed and replaced with
according notes this was done to provide
extra space by removing all non vital
components hormone therapy has been
proposed to counteract the long term
effects of the missing glands this
proposal is under review pending
analysis of possible complications
number nine
[Music]
and finally number 10 at least 15 other
alterations of unknown purpose given
this fact and the haphazard integration
of the quote useful components it is
believed that they were performed merely
to test the ability of such procedures
on other subjects investigations are
underway as to whether doctor is
planning to at present any theories as
to the purpose behind these alterations
are speculative at best
as dr. died during the raid in which
scp-198 see notes and they only
surviving records of his research or a
single half-burned
spiral bound notebook consisting mostly
of cryptic notes regarding a higher
purpose history as CP 191 was recovered
by foundation agents during a brief
collaborative effort with a global
occult coalition in which a raid was
conducted on the laboratory of dr. a
suspected member of scp-198 s subject
recovered from the laboratory all other
test subjects expired during the raid
either disposed off by doctor or
eliminated as hostiles by the task force
preliminary assessment concluded that
full reconstruction was impossible that
the components introduced were too
technologically advanced to risk
becoming widely known and that it could
be a source of valuable data regarding
if kept alive subject was classified as
scp-198
it's disappearance and those of the
other test subjects was later blamed on
a local serial killer who was arranged
to be killed in prison while awaiting
trial
addendum 191 - 1 testing of scp-198
note this is a test log for exploring
the capabilities of a CP 191 please
remember that scp-198 joule and not an
entertainment center any test involving
gains or other recreational technology
should be conducted in a professional
manner and not for amusement subject
paint a ubiquitous simple drawing
program instructions interface with a
computer via USB port and draw specified
pictures using paint results SCP 191 was
instantly able to emulate the functions
of a mouse and a keyboard when showed
any photograph 191 was able to reproduce
it within seconds using only the pencil
tool creating copies indistinguishable
from the original after the test was
recorded it was noticed that SCP 191 had
continued drawing in additional paint
files SCP 191 appeared surprised and
opened a text file on-screen claiming
that it had not realized it was still
drawing the following drawings were
discovered three people wearing what
appeared to be GOC uniforms standing in
a burning office pointing guns at a man
across the room the man is committing
suicide by gunshot wound to the head his
face obscured by blood an adult and
child trick-or-treating the child is a
girl wearing makeup similar to that worn
by Boris Karloff in Frankenstein and the
adult
[Music]
next test subject the video game
instructions attempt to emulate the
functions of a Wii mote and play a video
game result test began poorly as scp-198
paired motor skills caused it to snap
the disc in two before it could place it
in the console as CP 191 became
distressed it then stared at the disc
and the red light for its I changed to
green for a moment when dr. returned
with a fresh disc less than two minutes
have passed the game was already running
on the machine doctors inquired as to
how that had happened and a message
appeared on the screen saying I looked
at the ones and zeros and I loaded those
in I'm sorry I know I'm not supposed to
do it this way but I didn't want you to
waste a disc please don't be angry the
CP 191 still seemed fearful of reprimand
even after being reassured that it was
doing excellently scp-198 a perfect
run-through of the game despite the fact
that it did not make any physical
movements consistent with the weed
controls and the last test subject a
well known video effects program a 40
second video file from a security camera
located in the employee cafeteria
instructions perform a series of video
enhancement techniques used by forensic
detectives on the popular television
drama techniques that cannot actually be
done in reality
number one zoom and enhance scp-198 to
zoom in on the window over the parking
lot and read the license plates on the
cars which were illegible from this
distance the actual license plates had
been photographed for reference number
two on crop as CP 191 was asked to
shrink the video by 100 pixels on every
side and fill in the blank space with
what it believed the rest of the
cafeteria looked like again the data was
not actually available in the video and
number three rotate camera as CP 191 was
informed of the exact location and angle
of the other security camera in the
cafeteria and asked to render the scene
as viewed from that angle filling in the
parts that the current camera did not
see the actual footage from the second
camera was requisitioned and held for
reference result as CP 191 could not
understand the instructions at first dr.
P and to provide a lengthy explanation
and then stand behind a CP 191 and given
instructions one step at a time it was
several minutes before the test could
even begin however once scp-198 got
started the videos and frames were
finished in less than seven minutes of
which at least three were spent watching
the rendering progress bar number one
zoom and enhance test scp-198 ins plates
complete with photorealistic scratches
and dents
however the place were found not to
match the license plates on the vehicles
as CP 191 typed the data wasn't there so
I had to guess number two uncropped test
as CP 191 expanded the video canvas and
filling in what was in the blank space
rendering the extra image seamlessly it
did not match the actual cafeteria but
once again
the data was not in the video file an
SCP 191 had been forced to guess number
three rotate camera test the generated
video matched the angle of the second
camera perfectly and almost everything
visible from the angle of c1 matched the
scene in c2 very closely as before
places not visible were very different
one table only visible in c2 that had
been seedings was now in the generated
video seating doctors and agent the
attending doctor and agents supervising
SCP 191 eating lunch and talking
although there were many visual
differences between the original videos
and SCP 191 s copies many on-site
personnel were unable to determine which
ones were the forgeries psychological
analysis by dr. glass SCP 191 has
responded fairly well to containment
it is completely docile and cooperative
and when not being interacted with it
spends most of its time sitting or
curled up in a fetal position this may
be a sign of distress but is more likely
for physical comfort as normal body
movements and postures are difficult
mental acuity is questionable although
capable of rapid data analysis and
communications when physically linked to
a computer system it seems unable to
follow conversations with human beings
unless the conversin speaks slowly and
uses simple words complex tasks are also
impossible unless it is guided at every
step its mood seems consistent though
somewhat inscrutable it continually
effects melancholy and will not make eye
contact unless asked to and any attempts
to induce a cheerful or humorous mood
have proven fruitless however it shows
no signs of ongoing mental distress and
claims through a computer interface and
it is feeling well
to date SCP 191 has not requested access
to or any information about any
acquaintances it had before its
abduction okay I think that about does
it for today thank you all for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andre Bashar dr.
mortis Cody tench
Pierce M Hamlin sy7 actual rebellion
fidelia's untie verbal if you would like
a personalized thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the volgen thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]